♪♪♪
>>> IS THIS DOWNTON ABBEY?
>> YES.
>> A LETTER.
♪♪♪
>> WOW.
>> THE KING AND QUEEN ARE COMING
TO DOWNTON.
>> HERE?
BUT THIS IS A CASTLE.
>> WELL, WE'LL NEVER PULL THIS
OFF.
>> THE BELOVED TELEVISION SHOW
IS NOW A FEATURE FILM.
>> AND IT'S MOSTLY CLEANING.
>> WE ONLY HAVE 80 SERVANTS.
BUTLERS, UNDERBUTLERS AND
VALETS.
IT'LL NEVER GET DONE IN TIME.
>> HOW LONG DO WE HAVE?
>> A YEAR AND A HALF.
>> WERE THE STAKES IN THE SHOW
ALWAYS THIS LOW?
I GUESS THEY WERE.
>> YOUR HAIR IS SO MODERN.
>> DO YOU LIKE IT?
>> YES.
>> "EXCITING FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
LIKE THE SHOW," RAVES THE
"BOSTON GLOBE."
>> MISS, WE FOUND MUD.
>> WHERE?
>> AT THE BOTTOM OF THE LAKE.
>> GOOD.
THAT'S WHERE MUD GOES.
>> "I ABSOLUTELY LOVE THIS
FILM," SAY ALL MOMS.
>> I NEED YOUR HELP.
>> NO.
PROBLEM.
>> "SO SOOTHING I WAS ON THE
BACK OF MY SEAT."
>> WE'LL SERVE BREAD.
LONG BREAD.
BUTTER.
CHICKEN MEAT.
SLURPERS.
NIBBLES.
LITTLE BAD CAKES.
TWICE MURDERED PIGS.
AND OF COURSE CHICAGO STYLE DEEP
DISH PIZZA.
>> "FEELS LIKE WATCHING THE SUN
SET ON WHITE PEOPLE AS A WHOLE."
>> I'M HAPPY.
>> BLIMEY.
>> YOUR MAJESTIES.
WELCOME TO DOWNTON ABBEY.
>> THIS HAS BEEN AN AD FOR "THE
JOKER."